we begin with this startling admission
by Rudy Giuliani leaves president Trump
facing new legal questions this morning
about whether he knew it about an
attempt to silence stormy Daniels the
president's new lawyer says that mr.
Trump actually repaid the 130,000
dollars at attorney Michael Cohen gave
to the adult film star after an alleged
affair this contradicts the president's
past statement that he was unaware of
Cohen's payment Giuliani says mr. Trump
did not know about the specifics of the
arrangement we shang is at the white
house was a good morning good morning
Anthony president Trump is firing off
tweets right now saying Cohen was
working on a retainer and not connected
to the campaign adding these sorts of
non-disclosure agreements are common
among celebrities presumably talking
about himself but CBS News has learned
that last night White House staffers
were stunned to see Giuliani making the
same revelations on television giving
you a fact now that you don't know it's
not campaign money no campaign finance
violation Rudy Giuliani said Wednesday
night the president Trump reimbursed his
personal attorney Michael Cohen for a
$130,000 payment Cohen made to keep
adult film star stormy Daniels quiet
eleven days before the election funneled
through law firm and the president
repaid it oh I didn't know what he did
yeah that contradicts what the president
said on Air Force One last month
[Music]
Giuliani said at the time the president
did not know the details he didn't know
about the specifics of it as far as I
know but he didn't know about the
general arrangement that Michael would
take care of things like this
in a February statement Cohen admitted
to using his own personal funds to
facilitate the payment adding neither
the Trump Organization nor the Trump
campaign was a party to the transaction
Giuliani explained mr. Trump paid Cohen
back in increments of $35,000 when I
heard Cohen's retainer of 35,000 when he
was doing no work for the president mmm
I said that's how he's repaying that's
how he's repaying it Daniels's lawyer
michael avenatti said Giuliani's remarks
could possibly indicate bank fraud or
money laundering Rudy Giuliani based on
what I've just seen stated that there
were bogus law firm bills well guess
what that's fraud that's illegal
Giuliani's admission comes amid a big
shuffle in the White House legal team
senior attorney Ty Cobb announced a
surprise resignation yesterday and he'll
be replaced by former Clinton
impeachment attorney
Emmett flood now this change is viewed
as a shift in strategy in the Russia
investigation changing from a
conciliatory tone to an aggressive one
Gail all right we should hang thank you
very much